hommage comme l'attestent m
on jouait le tout chaque âge
séverine ferrer firmine richard et
valérie butt
parce que des gens
derrière
commençons d'un permis ça va voilà des
toutes ses toiles affiche doit fond la
caisse à la grande comédie à 20 heures
du mercredi au samedi
alors qui fait le pitch six caissières
de supermarché dans un vestiaire ah
ouais d'accord femmes
six personnalités différentes six femmes
différentes
six destins croisés tout un programme
tu parles d'un bonheur alors disons
c'est qu'on ait viré nous et on sortait
bien la preuve
ouais c'est là que commence comment ça
se passerait alors écoute pour rien au
monde je retournerais oui enfin je suis
vraiment heureuse sur scène ce soir et
pendant un sauvetage un nom du tout est
en fait la télé ne me manque pas
j'accueille aussi francesca antoniotti
alors désolé je suis candidate à la star
ac
aujourd'hui vous animez donc un jeu sur
le foot sur tps foot vous trouvez
comment l'équipe de france là un petit
peu timide là mais bon si lens est mal
barrés la ferme a enregistré wells le
dire même si on y croit
un nom mais bon il faut pas être
défaitiste je sais je sais ce que je me
dis aussi de toute façon face à la
suisse la france n'a jamais réussi à
faire des bas monde et exploiterait
quick halal et comment là demain avec la
corée bah je crois de les voir
baccalauréat quant à toi je suis près
d'une heure ils jouent pas au foot ils
envoient des bombes atomiques bien bon
ben voilà fils maintenant j'accueille le
dj un dj star
ça va alors on va entendre un morceau de
dope pendant le générique de fin
tout à fait un sétois ça ouais bon mais
un premier maxi à premier maxi cd il est
bon en même temps un je le montre à la
caméra ce qui me plaît ce mec si voilà
aide en tête chez circus company si bien
les maxi en pépinière vous connaissez le
principe d'abord séparés qui donc c'est
l'équipe de mareva d'intérêt de bonnes
contre l'équipe de firmine attention
firmine chef d'equipe attention poing
sur la table
elle est déjà dans la vie tu es prêt
non
et
oui
dans les villes ou les vidéos qui me dit
procol harum la campagne matches nuls en
rap c'est pas nul mais là tu as été nul
c'est sur les femmes c'est bon bon dos
et les beach boys donc c'est un pauvre
équipe de pia ménages français oui c'est
un maxi
ouais ouais
tu passes 10 ans m6 tu connais pas les
dacquois un peu jeune on chausse
l'aventuré voire j'écoute qu'ils ont
c'est vrai ça fait un partout
franchement là séverine franchement j'ai
pas sur 100 tu as appelé nicolas de
tavernot pourra pas tranquille
g
bah
jean
m
cheikh ahmadou leur bec bec dans l'eau
voilà on continue non
et l'on connaît
quand
bien deux points pour l'équipe de mareva
galanter qui n'a rien trouvé
monsieur et deux ans pour faire un dix
ont continué
bush
bien oui c'est pas catherine ça
ressemble c'est vrai oui ça ressemble
sauf que c'est coûteux
ouais bon on continue nos mahzem papa
ouais
oui
dans cette équipe
l'équipe de miles est super fort à toi
lui dit
et
oui
composé par elaine mc oui on continue
ouais
m
vainqueur
bravo l'an lao première note bravo
vraiment vraiment bravo on continue
elle
pour le bain
rassurant
une fois rêver
la vidéo
oui il ya des gens qui vont rentrer chez
eux ce soir et qui vont lui coûter sa
[ __ ] qu'est ce qu'on est vraiment ella
fitzgerald colère j'en ai marre mais
c'est ouais non c'est la première visite
mais oui
fabiano farah de dollars
on continue
et
là
c'est vrai tu manques et qui sort chez
tout le monde et chez les singes en soit
la maison la maison des blind test va
chanter dans la voiture si tu es sans
les montages sont les stations
c'est quoi ça c'est quoi ça laurent
baffie vous explose tous les records en
kit de crème elle le porc-épic america
avec sa cote est ce que si sa peine est
ce mal merci de ton la donne
conduits et
madame hamouri
waouh douter
à l'issue du par équipes c'est énorme
l'équipe de mareva galanter marque dix
fois
il s'appelle pour la place de 10 jeux
qu'est faut que je rappelle un matin
merci bien
alors donc à l'issue du par équipes
c'est un triomphe de l'équipe de mareva
alors oui c'était la zone est toujours
mieux c'est un buteur
j'ai des bons copains serré série des
banques au chacun pour sa gueule à toi
tu confonds
ça va
c'est lui par équipes j'ai dû m'arrêter
là il joue pour lui il affirmé il n'y
joue pour lui va il s'en fout voilà donc
non le maire est pas sauf il joue pour
lui je te dis salut par écrit par le
maire n'est pas sot firmine non jeu
s'est déconsidéré on continue
le maire georges et jean jaurès
et ma famille
la veille m
ohlsson
m
oui
et mon dieu
c'est l'autre lui est venue dans ces
émissions se montrent pas je sais c'est
mon idole et je retrouve pas son nom et
je sais tu veux milliers dans les gens
ce n'est pas youtube walkie et les
hollande
bon ça fait zéro donc maintenant c'est
très important évidemment le méga
banques ou prend d'autant plus
d'importance et un suspense qui atteint
des sommets tout est sûre ce méga bon
colorants concentrez-vous séverine bon
allez
et
c'est rien
il m'a dit m
nous
wen
oui
m
et c'est plié et voilà
le cas
ça soit un petit gars parties viennent
expliquent ces led zep ont en effet
cherché un rappeur qu'est ce qu'ils
foutent et j'en étais tu vois oh
lalalalalalalalala la culture
d'aujourd'hui
ben voilà donc c'est fabrice barrao
fabrice ya plus rien derrière
c'était tout le monde en parle
ge
si tu reviens dans la vie je me mets au
pas
or dominique pas au cha campagne
télévisée contre la sclérose en plaques
mareva galanter l'album s'appelle new
couillet by mareva sortie le 19 juin
le single s'appelle pourquoi pas moi
azouz begag de joie en concert le 19
juin à l'occasion du forum international
des peuples autochtones
tunis ap au victoria abril
l'album s'appelle buttes chaumont ce
blazer en concert à montpellier a montré
à béziers montauban qu'un format et le
30 novembre n'était on met paris coran
fanage a plus qu'à antoine casubolo
coluche l'accident avec jean de bus et
aux éditions privé il y peu jo coluche
l'histoire d'un mec j'ai flammarion bd
vino passion animal c'est ce gars c'est
l'ennemi funèbres et djida de james
robinson chez michel lafon
fabrice gaignault et qui joue et j'ai
les six teams gbaya revoilà séverine
ferrer firmine richard
elle est libre car pour la caisse à la
grande comédie m 2 mj bonne chose quand
je ne dis primes de match toulouse-lyon
sont des belges scouts et guides
génissac l'album le double ville zabel l
orteil raté au fait voilà c'est d'être
dans l'embarras
rendez vous la semaine prochaine
à